tu fais quoi j'ai créé un brouillon de
ma vie
que nous le voulions ou non que nous
sachions nous nous sommes responsables
de ce qu'ils nous unir à demain
et pour partie nous engageons l'avenir
nous voulons mettre fin à l'avortement
clandestin
il faut rester ensemble rien ne doit
nous séparer
c'est une annonce très fière de toi
je félicite madame veil pour son
élection l'espoir c'est dans l'europe
que je place
votre travail madame fait la vocation ce
n'est pas un travail c'est une vocation
le fn veut mettre le bordel faut partir
chamakh
être papa
pato
survécu au pire que vous
m
j'avais ton âge
[Applaudissements]
tous les jours je vois mon
c'est ma force
[Applaudissements]
et mon modèle
thome combat c'est elle
corel
[Musique]